barbar congratulations and the
publication of what is this your 11th
12th book and I had to count them
because some of them are co-authored or
collections well congratulations on the
publication of baton switched which I
very much enjoyed reading and I'd love
to just go through the book a little bit
and engage you and some of the
provocative things that you say in the
book just to set out the scene for
people who haven't had a chance to see
the book yet you essentially go on a
six-month job search to find it 10
months ten months to find a job in white
class white collar America corporate
America right and why don't you tell us
a little bit about in general what you
came away with from this 10 month
experience well I should say what
inspired me to do such a well
fool-hearty saying it now it seems to me
looking back since writing nickel and
dimed which is about low-wage
blue-collar folks I just get tons of
letters from people in that situation
you know we're barely getting by and I
began to notice that a lot of these
letters are coming from people I
wouldn't have expected people with
college degrees even with master's
degrees people who had held pretty what
they thought were secure jobs and had
lost those jobs in a layoff or something
and there they are
you know sunk right down to seven eight
nine dollars an hour so that's what made
me wonder I did I even made me think
well I'm not done with the subject of
poverty you know yet I have to
investigate this actor I have to see
what's going on so I took the same
approach that I did with nickel and
dimed I said well I will put myself
physically in that situation I will go
undercover as a white-collar job seeker
fake resume new name afraid the old name
might turn up too many Google entries or
something and just see how hard is it to
get a job and I'm meant to get you know
I wanted to get a corporate job as a PR
person have you ever had a corporate job
before no
that might explain a little bit you're
definitely yeah no I mean this is really
from I'm really coming from the outside
but a good strong resume I thought
though I upgraded it once along the way
quite a bit as a PR person because that
goes with being a writer I wasn't saying
I there was I could do anything that I
can't do right communications writing
speaking whatever let me read from one
of the first passages in the book the
introduction you say that in about 2002
that many such tales of hardship were
coming from people who were once members
in good standing of the middle class
college graduates and former occupants
of middle level white-collar positions
and this seems to be one of the themes
that you've written about for the last
20 years or so which is that there's a
shrinking middle class in America
something that a proposition that I'm
not necessarily in agreement with but
why don't you discuss that and why do
you think that the middle class is
shrinking I mean if you look at some of
the economic indicators in the United
States today they're pretty positive
that median income for a family is now
52 thousand dollars a year we have
record low unemployment today four point
nine percent just came out last week so
I'm not sure that picture is as dire as
you portray it to be so can you flesh
that out a little bit about the decline
in the middle class well I'm not you
know I'm not making any claim in this
book that the middle class is physically
shrinking well you know in previous
books and writings you've haven't you
made the case in there certainly was
evidence of that and I did write for The
New York Times at that point about about
that we are becoming and I think no one
would question is so much more polarized
society
you mean with respect to incomes with
respect to incomes on wealth right and
you know that that's no longer an issue
of contention I don't think between but
no my concern here was really more
individual suffering what what's
happening here like I got a letter last
just a few days ago from a 43 year old
woman a chemical engineer who was
talking about her experience going in
and out of show
since the layoffs she experienced you
know that's that makes me wonder you
know what what is exactly going on
because I had always imagined the white
collar corporate folks it's kind of well
hey they've got it made you know they've
got a steady income they're going to
retire with a pension I think I was
really wrong I did not understand the
degree of insecurity and stress at those
levels I had thought were relatively
privileged and you know in the in the
last year your newspaper The Wall Street
Journal the LA Times and The New York
Times all had big series on class in
America and one point that comes out
clearly in all of them is this degree of
uncertainty in the middle class right
volatility of income incomes wildly
fluctuating from year to year and mostly
that is due to layoffs firings
downsizings all those things and despite
all that though we do see you know
income gains we have seen as I said you
know you said in the book that you were
trying to find a $50,000 a year job with
health insurance the median income in
the United States they said it's about
fifty two thousand dollars so the
average person does have a job that sort
of fits that profile one thing that I
think I would never expect to is usually
- well let me ask you this because you
know I had written a book a few years
ago about how things are getting better
economically in America and I made the
contention that I'd like to lay out to
you which is that for all the you know
suffering that is happening in the
economic unemployment that's out there
that this is still about as good a time
to live in America than any other time
and I wonder whether you would it seems
like you're suggesting that things are
getting worse for workers do you I would
say they are they are getting they are
getting worse I'll give you some
examples but in terms of the overall
numbers you know yet employment just
fell down by from now five to four point
nine percent which is we hope good are a
good sign but here's the kind of
baffling
part is that at the same time poverty
rose it went up from what 12 and a half
to twelve point seven or some percent
and that is a gross underestimate I mean
we know that that they just the way they
measure poverty is still based almost
entirely on the price of food which
doesn't show much inflation or hasn't
really done these days of high oil
prices housing prices or child care and
medical cost so if there's always I know
but it has gone up every year for the
past five years the fact that is no
longer coupled to employment is
something to worry about because that
suggests that a lot of people are
working in jobs that don't lift them out
of poverty now that's what I wrote about
in nickel and dime and here in baton
switch I'm talking about people who had
once been doing well and often fall down
to that level of being working and poor
at the same time so I think there are
some reasons to worry I'm not I can't
compare this point in history to all of
American history and you know another
thing that's sort of a gross indication
of in addition to the like the series
that your own newspaper had about this
writing terrible uncertainty in the
middle class is that decline and things
like company pensions you know in the
1970s something like 40% of all workers
had a company pension right now it's 20%
health insurance less and less of that
is covered by employers so those are the
bad signs I mean I don't want to have an
argument on this issue of benefits
because I've been looked at the evidence
on this I'm not sure that's that's
actually accurate that that companies
are providing less benefits in fact if
you if you look at the statistics it
indicates that that companies are
actually giving more benefits than ever
in fact the average American now again
these are media numbers burns earns
about $18 an hour but when you include
benefits health insurance pensions
childcare or other things that companies
provide it's about 26 dollars an hour so
about $8 an hour that Americans are
working today on
Everage are these very fringe benefits
that you say Americans not receiving not
only that but if you look at the range
of benefits that Americans receive any
more Americans have flex time at work
more Americans get their childcare
through their work more more Americans
have more vacation time than ever before
when you take all those things into
account I'm not so sure that the
benefits are disappearing well those are
the numbers I could just tell you those
are the number I mean I view our
pensions few people have pensions fewer
people have insurance and what you know
that means one of the things that
happens is that your contribution as a
worker to the premium goes up an option
or the benefits themselves decrease but
you know the interesting thing that you
allude to and he had not to get too far
ahead of the picture is you do talk
about this issue of health insurance and
how important that is for Americans and
you make the case that maybe we should
try to disengage the employer from
health insurance altogether which oddly
enough me coming from the right you
[ __ ] the left I agree with you on that
now in terms of what we might replace
that with we might disagree I think you
should agree as a person whose
sympathies are more to the corporate
leadership side I think it's ridiculous
to say that employers have this
responsibility and my I'm looking at
that mainly for the point of view of the
worker right which is that you're not
going to have one job or two jobs or
three jobs in your life at exact we all
know that right
there's been a real change and maybe
you'll explain some of this to me more
in the corporate culture since the late
80s you know there's people come and go
what I mean leave no question I have
seen estimates of up - and this is from
sociologist Richard Sennett
up to that you might hold eleven jobs
today after when you went to the job
used to be in the 50s I know my guys my
dad had like two corporate jobs right
and I saw this so how could be tied to
each it can't be tight and then I can
also even say it from the business side
you know look if GM is sinking under the
weight of benefits like health right
what about the the grocery store in the
corner right you know you can't expect
them to do that now the way I fully
agree with that
and you know my solution to that is
actually to by the way one of the
reasons that corporations got into the
business of providing health care was
was primarily through the tax code that
that if a company gives health benefits
to its workers it those are when I get
those benefits as an employee I don't
have to pay taxes on it whereas if they
give me a higher wage
I am taxed on it so this led some what
I've always argued is maybe we should we
should take away the the tax benefit for
health insurance so that it's on a level
playing field with wages let workers get
a higher wage and then buy their own
health insurance whereas you seem to be
suggesting well maybe what we ought to
do different sure and what do you mean
what do you mean by universal health
care oh well I'm not but you know the
health policy expert anymore once I was
so many years ago but um you know for
one thing I have to respond just
personally here I'm a freelancer right
you know and I know what it's like to
shop for health insurance on the open
market as an individual of a certain age
you know it's just really nasty it's
expensive no I want that you know I
think that's a kind of risk that is
appropriately shared so you'd like
something more like a Canadian oh yes
absolutely even despite the problems
they have in Canada with waiting lines
and I mean I think a lot of Americans
wouldn't relish the idea of having a
Canadian style system because their
carer isn't is I mean we have a
different very different system we do
have a lot of uninsured people but we
have for those who do have insurance
they have a higher level of care that
are provided than people in Canada so
I'm wondering well that it's debatable I
mean and I think that's a debate they
can take on because they're Americans
were going to candidate for health care
all and vice-versa India for health care
Americans you go to India or they do no
no no this is this is medical tourism
isn't a whole interesting subject which
we shouldn't wander into but when you
can save $30,000 on your operation it's
worth the airfare let's talk a little
bit about one thing I found really fun
about the book
what's your whole experience trying to
find a job and this new kind of culture
of networking and all of these self-help
books
so on which to me have always been kind
of a fad I've never really seen the
value in it that was very much
reinforced by what I read it in your
book why don't you just tell us about
some of your fun
madam fun is the right word but your
interesting experiences with the
networking groups and and all of these
self-help books and so on where any of
them of value do you think my initial
idea was I am so naive I am so you know
on familiar with the corporate world I'm
gonna get whatever help I can get and
I'm gonna pay for it if necessary so I
started off with coaches career coaches
I you know what I was beginning to
understand is there's a whole industry
that has grown up around white-collar
unemployment just since the mid nineties
it's called the transition industry
right so you don't have to be alone in
your home you know being depressed and
isolated all the time you can get out
there and be with people who are also
unemployed and there's just tons of
things to keep you busy but they don't
help you find a job they're worse I got
some useful tips here there I got help
with my resume
there was an occasional coach who had
some good you know I thought useful tips
I would never have thought about because
of my ignorance perhaps but it was
mainly it was through the looking glass
into a surreal world I had not imagined
you know day one I go to I find a career
coach locally so I actually meet with
and his his deal is to in coach you
using Wizard of Oz dolls and a plastic
Elvis Presley doll thrown in don't ask I
can't explain us but he and all these
other coaches they want to give you a
personality test right away right my
personality one time my personality
turned out to be not so good
envious melancholy well good and loving
and Andy is a melancholy and my downside
that I had to work on the guy told me
was that a person like me would not be a
good writer could
but you know another time I turned out
actually to be a sort of a CEO type
there's no consistency in these tests no
and and they're completely discredited
right scientific so why you ask the
question why do they why maybe they
don't I mean maybe this is all do other
corporations do it the corporations are
my list the huge numbers of serious
major corporations that use the antia
gram test is this the the one device
that's the one derived from Sufism
ancient Celtic lore Jesuit philosophy
Egyptian I don't know so you think this
is all just a waste of time and money
completely but how do people get fooled
into I mean core I'm talking about the
corporations now well why do they use
these tests well I agree with you I love
me let me sort of challenge you at a
point though I mean one thing about the
book though is that because in the end
you really didn't find a job that you
were looking for a big kind of a job
right I mean it wasn't exactly you know
what's our ideal job so maybe you just
went about it all the wrong way I mean
you see you sort of said I did all the
right things but maybe really you didn't
I mean you were sort of following this
prescription than these job consultants
Madonna maybe that's not how you get
working right you have to go out there
you have to mingle with people and
business card is networking about well
the trouble is who are going to network
with say well and I know one of the
things you described in the book is
spending a lot of time with other
unemployed Pia and to me you know what
I'm reading this time say well wait a
minute you know these aren't the people
I want to hang out with if I'm trying to
find a job I mean I mean it might be for
for you know a network in terms of you
know making us all feel good because
we're on the same boat but those aren't
the kind of people necessarily who gonna
give you it exactly what am i coach
scolded me hang out with those people
right and but you know it's you the hope
is still that you run into somebody who
says oh you know I I know somebody's
looking for a PR person with a strong
health background which was my
presume you know my identity so you know
it's I maybe I did it all wrong
but I did what other people are doing
for example you put your razor today
it's all about the automated you put
your resume on all the job monster
hotshot value nothing comes back right
nothing and of course I usually I you
know I think that if as they tell you
what no this is gonna go out to
thousands and thousands right yeah
they're even resume blasters right right
blasted to millions of companies which
must be unwanted spam I'm sure okay
but you know so you do that you you know
I read the book say I did I had a
makeover right all right this is I'm
well I'm not exactly a mitral full
corporate I'm not suited up entirely
right this minute but um you know I did
I think everything a person could
rationally do now you can still say I
had some flaws and there are things I
did wrong but by the end of the book you
know I'm when I went back and actually
interviewed some of the people I've met
along the way a lot of these people who
were smart with strong corporate
backgrounds they were still looking or
they had gone out to word I came away
with from all of us which was really
entertaining it's a good read is this
whole process is just BS that a lot of
the stuff that the coaches are telling
you to do really don't have that much to
do with with getting a job in to some
extent I almost felt encouraged that you
can't sort of be us you can't change
yourself you can't you can't go into an
interview and tell an employee or
somebody you're not and and let me just
read a passage that I loved in the book
you said I am NOT the only phony in the
job searching business what I've been
learning from Kimberly and to a certain
extent also from the stolid Joann is how
to lie how to plump up an
undistinguished resume how to project a
kind of confidence I neither feel nor
deserve to feel deception is part of the
game well maybe that was part of the
problem that you were sort of trying to
be somebody that you're not well they're
always they are you know consistently
every business advice book in a success
book and everything same advice be
positive be up the beat working yeah and
and that if you have show any trace of
being negative or perhaps you Harbor
some resentment from your last layoff or
firing that's gonna show and that's
gonna sink you that's a universal advice
to the job seeker I found that a little
creepy right I mean all right you can't
go to a resume and just sulk right we
know that right but where does the
seriousness what you know what why does
that matter
look if I'm a great PR person or a great
chemical engineer or whatever so what if
I'm not smiling every single minute like
that right you know III think that there
is I got the feeling and you can correct
me if I'm wrong because you know more
about the corporate world if there's a
lot of people going around with smiley
faces all the time
because that's how they think they have
to behave and they actually think that
conforming like that is more important
than getting the job done one of the
things that I I disagree with you on is
that I'm more bullish and upbeat about
the earth economy obviously than you are
but there's no question that we are
going through this incredible transition
in the economy and there are white color
people who have had good-paying jobs for
a long time that get this place from
their jobs partly because of globalism
and all these other outsourcing moves
and other factors that you talk about
that's got to be you know you were sort
of play-acting and doing this because
you knew even if I don't get a job I'm a
writer I'm you know but for these other
for the normal person who's going
through this it's got to be just a
devastating and a lot of a lot has been
written about the psycho psychological
damage of job loss depression that's
almost universal because you feel it's a
worthless or you know and it's not only
your income which is pretty big but it's
also your feeling of self-worth get her
self-worth from work most of us it's
this whole process that you talk about
it sort of degrading really oh and then
there yeah and then you know so you find
people drinking too much and I talked to
people who admitted to that provider if
I included that in the book
marital breakups you know all these
things that ensue right very rapid
in the in the wake of jobless so no I
said right up front I'm not gonna feel
that I'm not because hey I'm doing my
job you know I'm being my job as a
journalist while I do this so I cannot
report on the the in you know subjective
experience right and pain right job loss
however I could say one thing I began to
feel as months went by was a sense of
rejection worse than rejection really
because I said you don't get rejection
no it's right notice the never be
rejected and I thought how do you get
attention how do you I mean I've read
recently about people who put on tuxedos
to go to networking events or you know
next they'll be you get notice right
have sandwich sports with their resumes
on because you you know especially when
you read that these companies today are
not even likely to have a human being
reading the resumes for monster.com and
the other job boards they're likely to
stay on them with a computer which is
just looking for keywords what if you
don't know the key well I think a lot of
people who are gonna read your book are
gonna be people who are just displaced
white-collar workers looking for hints
and looking for ideas what what what do
you tell those people and what advice
would you haven't gone through this for
ten months and only with marginal
success what advice would you give
people who have been out of a job for a
year who are white collar maybe they
were a management level they can't find
another job well I don't say the first
be very careful how you spend your money
be very you spent a lot of money in this
$6,000 on these if you're unemployed you
can't know what people to do I mean they
think well this is a good investment
I've got to take my savings my ass
that's my severance pay and put it all
into that I'd say be really careful
right don't be sucked in is going to be
what you said bs so about you it's going
to be kind of mind games it's gonna be
new agey semi therapeutic nonsense don't
you know I I don't have anything
terribly positive to say about what you
might do but you know
what not to do maybe I'm right yeah
don't be taken in by the lures would be
one thing I do think it's good to get
together with other people in the same
situation though mm-hmm as a support
that's an old American thing I support
great the self-help group to get
together so you don't feel alone you
don't you know you can help manage that
feeling of depression and worthlessness
and you know I think one thing there's
missing in all these networking events
is a chance for people to really meet
and tell their stories nothing I think
would be more helpful than to sing ah
that happened to me too right you know
I'm not alone I'm not worthless right so
and does that happen in these not enough
right now you guys simple view you I
mean when you go to these groups did
they view you as competitors or it's not
that that you use I found in the groups
I went to which may not be a hundred
percent representative of course is that
you don't really get a chance to
interact that much with other people
we're in your situation you've got a guy
at the front of the room who's lecturing
preaching you know there's a lot of
evangelical Christians who are in this
sort of business of coaching people to
get new jobs and you know you know you
you barely get a chance to say hello to
people next to you one thing I meet a
lot of young college students who come
to Washington looking for their first
job and I oftentimes the first job is
the hardest to get and why especially in
in this town and I always advise people
get a job even if it's not a great job
get a job because the best way to get a
new job is to be employed that to some
extent if you're unemployed you become
the most stigmatized after a while you
don't really talk about that that much
in this book and in fact maybe one
philosophical disagreement that you and
I might have of just about the dynamics
of the labor forces I really do believe
there's a kind of upward mobility in
this American society that that there is
no such thing as a dead-end job that
that you know you see immigrants who
come in some of these low-paying jobs
and and they do rise up the economic
ladder of success which is to me a sort
of uniquely American characteristic of
our economy
do you believe that that the economic
ladder works in America today
not at all job I mean I I had some of
those jobs when I was doing research for
nickel and dime to me and with some of
them there just is no ladder in sight
look if you're cleaning I was a maid
with a house cleaning service there's no
there's nothing to rise into I was an
aide in a nursing home without higher
degrees there was no next step in that I
worked a Walmart now there there is a
ladder right upward unfortunately of
course we know that Walmart you know is
being sued a huge class-action suit for
sex discrimination so I wonder how fast
anyway leaving that one aside um you
know you and you know 70% of the people
work for Walmart are women yeah doesn't
doesn't that I think men should be suing
Walmart for sexist you know it's the
management levels that it's hard to get
into what but you know look if you I do
talk about trying other kinds of jobs
here I did apply for I applied for a
receptionist job I reply applied for
things like that
you know I started saying let's just
lower my site foot-in-the-door theory I
didn't get any responses on those either
tragically but there's a here's a here's
the problem most even if suppose you do
what many of the people I talked to
along the way did you take a so called
survival job you know you've been a
marketing person you've been an IT
person and now you start driving a limo
and now you go into Circuit City and you
stock inventory for $8 an hour how good
is that going to look on a resume you
know people know they they have to do
that to hold body and soul together a
little bit but it's not gonna it's not
gonna enhance your resume so it just
looks like more of a big gap we have to
take a break
afterwards with Barbara Ehrenreich and
Stephen Moore we'll continue in a moment
Dave Zirin makes the case that
professional sports in America are
closely tied to radical politics in his
new book what's my name fool tonight on
book TV hear the stories of Olympic
sprinter John Carlos and boxer Muhammad
Ali as well as former NFL player Pat
Tillman who joined the Army Rangers and
was killed in Afghanistan sports and
social activism at 10:30 p.m. Eastern
here on book TV British Member of
Parliament George Galloway opposed the
Iraq war
Vanity Fair columnist Christopher
Hitchens favored the removal of Saddam
Hussein's regime next Saturday at 9:00
p.m. Eastern they'll debate on book TV
George Galloway is the author of mr.
Galloway goes to Washington the Brit who
set Congress straight about Iraq and
Christopher Hitchens is the author of a
long short war the postponed liberation
of Iraq the war in Iraq next Saturday
night at 9:00 Eastern on book TV on
c-span
2
afterwards with Barbara Ehrenreich and
Stephen Moore continues however I wanna
talk a little bit about the special
problems that women face in white collar
labor force and again let me just read a
kind of fun passage from your book which
is that you say then there was the
vexing business of gender all of the
books warned that it's a lot trickier
for a woman to pass than this for a man
in part because the female quote uniform
is not yet as standardized as a man's so
it's easier for a woman to go wrong then
you say but the problem seems to go
deeper than that to the very biological
underpinnings of gender the features
that make a man sexually attractive
handsome nostalgie POIs etcetera also
work in his favor at the office while
female sexual attractiveness can torpedo
a woman's career shoulder length hair
and overly generous display of legs or a
too busty chest can all undermine a
woman's credibility beauty itself as a
handicap do you believe that's a big
problem that's but this is what I get
from the Dress for Success books
John Malloy's favorite classic book and
you know I I thought you know and I was
turned out to be wrong about this that
you know I had to look a little more
masculine I had to wear a suit jacket
with a straight lapel and a tailored
shirt under it and of course scarf and
all those things but I was scolded by my
makeover person who said that the you
can't have pointy lapels and things if
you're a woman
at least I couldn't I had to have curved
you said that I had been going too far
in the masculine direction with a
straight with the fine line and the
curved lines and you know so it's just
very hard to figure out because you
can't be as a woman you can't appear too
masculine
no but you also can't be too sexy or or
soft and famou too
so it's you know it's a really hard
thing to think I don't know if I ever
quite got it right
but I think you know it's more
standardized for guys I mean look at you
you're wearing the uniform you know what
it was hard but you know for a woman
it's it's um it's harder and you know my
you know but beyond the question of
gender here that's the thing that
worries me is why this extreme
insistence on conformity why does
everybody have to be the same well here
let me challenge that's gonna be fun
well if you look at especially high tech
I don't know if you went up to Silicon
Valley at all and talking all right
firms but that's a totally different
corporate culture than what you find my
Madison Avenue and in fact well I don't
know where the exact passage is but you
talk about sort of it's hard to get a
job if you're geekish you know or write
something to that effect
and when you go to Silicon Valley and
you just you know go into AI you know in
towel or to Microsoft I mean you've got
these guys who have bicycles in their
offices and they you know they probably
never worn a tie or clothes they're
liable but you know the corporate
culture is so different it was fairly
diverse except you know and I have I
have studied everything a secondary
source I can about this vital issue of
what to wear to work the internet bubble
is over the dot-com bubble is over well
it's coming no no we hope but you know
there was a moment there where sort of
creative self-expression became more
widely favored in the mid night in late
90s but all my source book a guidebook
said no more now in fact casual Friday
is being cut back in most workplaces we
do that was a little too everything too
much like hippies you know no that's not
my experience in fact I'm just surprised
just walking down the streets of
Washington DC now this may not be a
typical town but but it you know it's a
it's a white-collar town you I'm amazed
not just on Fridays but Mondays through
Thursdays of how few people you see
dressed in men dressed in suits or even
a tie is really becoming maybe you're
seeing the janitors but but it's
interesting I don't think no I mean all
right I'm coming from the outside of the
corporate world and I don't understand
that
fixation on conformity that you that you
are told that you if you deviate and I
was wearing a little Appel pin which I
thought was completely conservative and
everything my makeover guy said not
corporate inna see I just don't think
this is a fair critique I'm okay pair
this with the 1950's I mean a corporate
man and all that I mean conformity was
everything in corporate yeah I think it
I don't think we've changed enough I've
read this but stew or the organization
maybe and you know I think to me coming
from the outside all this seems very
strange what does it have to do with
whether you are a good person for your
job a PR person as I was if there's
something slightly unusual about your
lapel pants or you know I and I heard
another another coach saying to people
um he was warning guys he said um told
the story of a guy who'd failed to get a
wall street job because he was wearing a
blue shirt you're wearing a blue shirt I
noticed and that you have to wear a
white shirt on Wall Street and you think
what what all right so less true today
than it used to be okay but what there
has been you know there has been a kind
of pulling back since the dot-com bubble
burst back into a more fearful maybe
less self expressive kind of present
self presentation one of the changes in
the American economy that there's no
question about that could be either a
good thing or a bad thing depending on
your perspective I think you view it as
a kind of a bad thing is that more
Americans than ever are working for
themselves they're self-employed they're
working as consultants and that gives
workers a lot more flexibility they
don't have to conform to these dress
codes and so on but but you seem to
think that I'm not trying to put words
in your mouth but what do you make of
this because you sort of poopoo that as
well these are people aren't making a
lot of money and therefore so I
dissected myself as someone who'd been a
consultant for a couple of years that's
the kind of euphemism for unemployed
definitely everybody's insulting to
these days
the no I I think in fact you get a lot
of things in your inbox when you're job
searching you know when these companies
pick you up on from monster.com saying
they're sick of the rat race you know
you know want to be free you know make
you around you know promising that you
can sort of like dress and you know be
who wear like you want can be whatever
you are and be a nonconformist and that
means of course working at home doing
some kind or being going into sales that
you do from your home something like
that so yeah they hold out the promise
of nonconformity for what are really
sort of non jobs not that people can't
do quite well as freelancers or
consultants but you know we're talking
about no benefits we're talking about no
security no in no salary nothing that's
the downside of being a consultant what
advice do you give to people like my
wife we have three kids young kids she's
been out of she had a good job before
she had the kids but she took about
seven or eight years off to bring up the
kids while they were young now she's
trying to get back in the workforce she
knows hundreds of women just like her
who are totally frustrated partly
because the technological change the
workforce says is so different today
than it was even very worrisome thing
because you know when I my initial
resume I was going I had some gaps in it
that I was going to account for by home
making which is not a lie just that I've
always been a journalist at the same
time as being a mother and a homemaker
and I thought well that's a perfectly
legitimate thing I'm reinter in the
workforce right I've had a divorce or
whatever that has forced me back into it
but I remember this one coach who was
one of the the best coaches I had
actually saying when I said to him I can
you know how about if I explain the gap
in my resume through home making he said
you better have a pretty good story to
explain that have a good story you know
is this a weird to be a homemaker and
then I thought about all that you know
we read about a lot of younger women in
your wife's kind of position was highly
skilled professionals who take off a few
years with young children and think
they're going to get right back in I'm
afraid homemaking does not look good on
a resume and at eight years you know
from the point of view of a lot of
employers you might have been just
sitting
I'm collecting welfare right and that is
really really disturbing in terms of
woman's ability to you know achieve
equality keep ahead to help support
their families one very depressed let me
go on to the conclusion of the book
because you it's I think this is one of
the most interesting chapters at the
whole book when you tie it all together
and the lessons learned and you have a
very good eye view is a very depressing
paragraph here about the state of the
American worker today and I want to
search challenge your honor you said let
me just read this passage middle-class
Americans like myself and my fellow
seekers have been raised with the
old-time Protestant expectation that
hard work will be rewarded with material
comfort and security this has never been
true of the working class most of which
toils away at wages in commensurate with
the effort required do you you don't
believe in that the middle class worth
that work ethic works anymore in America
I mean it's that's a very depressing
tell you what makes me worry about that
is that you know first a lot of people
are laid off for you know no nothing
they did wrong at all you know and we
have a new wave of layoffs coming along
right now from a number of major
corporations just announced this summer
Hewlett Packard Shanaya Pfizer Ford for
example but what seemed really perverse
to me is that I also talked to a lot of
people who were let go precisely because
they had done well or apparently so they
so they told told me that they had had
recent promotions they had been praised
they had moved up like there's a guy in
there who said you know I've just been
told I'm gonna be let go because I'm
making more money than anybody else in
my department presumably he's making
that more money cuz he did a good job
what's wrong right and then a friend of
mine who works at GE recently told me
about the guy who goes the software guy
who goes to his boss and said I'd like a
raise and the boss says you wouldn't
want that it's like having a bull's-eye
painted on your back in other words the
more you make the more tempting a cost
cut you represent some bean counter is
going to look not at how well you're you
know what you've contributed to the
company they're gonna say hey
100 grand or 70 grand we can get rid of
that now that completely flies in the
face of the Protestant work ethic of
anything else when you no longer have
rewards coupled to achievement what are
you doing to people's heads the there
was a series in The Washington Post not
long ago about immigrant workers and in
some of the beach towns like Ocean City
Maryland and so on and it paints a very
different picture than you do I mean one
of the things that these immigrants many
of them from East Europe talked a lot
about is what they really loved about
America is that this is a country that
they've found firsthand that you if you
work hard you can get ahead that you're
rewarded and that's not true and Poland
or maybe not true would be true in
Russia so there's a it seems to me
there's a lot of contrary evidence to
this conclusion that my my job is to
look at the downside my job is to look
at the underside my job is to look at
the pain threat part and to see who's
hurting and why but you'll at least
acknowledge that there is a look my dad
started as a miner you know mile deep in
the copper mines of Butte Montana and he
rose to be a high-level executive in a
multinational corporation incredible
corporation your dad was the coordinate
man so you know I saw this amazing
trajectory of upward mobility right but
I'll say this about my dad too
you know he never looked down at the
people who didn't make it he's knew what
the obstacles were he knew how hard it
was he knew what was holding people down
so I think a mob heart and a lot of my
social conscience comes from those
origins which were quite poor you talk a
little bit about the some your policy
prescriptions for example you talk about
something you say most recent corporate
tax breaks is provided by the
appealingly titled American Jobs
Creation Act although it does not do
anything to encourage job creation well
that actually I'm not sure that's true I
mean this was the that was a a bill that
basically allowed corporations to
repatriate capital United States
there have been just in the last couple
of months tallies about how much capital
has been brought in so it's someone that
every one hundred billion dollars of
money that that is now a lot of that is
being reinvested in America and plant
and equipment and computers and
technology some of it
repay trading I think fourteen and a
half billion dollars at the same time
announcing layoffs of 14,500 people that
is not a job creation effort and in fact
the New York Times your competitor
newspaper there
I had an editorial the lead editorial
when one of them last week was about
this scandal that we have companies who
are repay treating billions of dollars
coming back and having to pay very low
tax about 5% on that while they are
laying off American workers but a lot of
contrary evidence of companies bringing
back this Calvin we're talking about it
give me some money give me an example of
money that is actually taking it's
repatriated money and hiring more
Americans right now well we know that
we've had records just in the last six
months we've have record job creation
and we know that a lot of this money is
being invested in in plant no you're
right some of it is just being
reinvested in terms of dividends but
even that's not necessarily a bad thing
for American workers because about half
the American workforce now actually own
stock in the companies that they work
force out is they're getting a benefit
from the increased return aren't they I
mean that this is one of the new
dynamics of the American economy the
kind of worker owner that we talk a lot
about the although the amount of stock
owned by the average worker is a rather
minut pair to you know big stockholders
and everything so I wouldn't exaggerate
that but I do think we can't have things
like hewlett-packard getting this huge
tax break in the name of tack job
creation while it cuts people off yeah
they get cuts people I'll let cut
someone's you know there has been good
job creation but we have to also look at
what kind of jobs are being created are
they jobs that you can really live on
that have benefits and secondly we have
to look at job loss this year the
estimates are that we will lose another
million
jobs a million job losses will occur
right I think this is the fourth year in
a row when we've been up to that larger
numbers well now that's a million but
there was also been a net two million
jobs created so we're losing jobs in
some fields and gaining raps and others
but I'm saying we have to look at the
quality of the jobs that are being
created which had tended to be the sort
of low paid service sector jobs but the
job losses I'm asking you to think about
the personal turmoil the devastation
represented by a million people losing
their jobs sure every year what do you
what do we do about that though because
you know this is a new economy whether
we like it or not the computer and
globalization and technology are just
rapidly changing the workforce we can't
sort of stand a Thorat of history and
say stop I
what kind of remedies do you I've given
that that we are in a kind of new
technological age where as you say the
cycle is churning much faster people are
being displaced from their jobs other
jobs are being created well would you
like to see don't wouldn't ascribe this
all to technology well some of it is but
you know we had a corporate vote came in
in the 90s of down of getting leaner and
leaner to please shareholders to the
point where man and some management
gurus are kind of beginning to say this
is silly because all you have left
behind is really stressed out overworked
people who can't really to jobs so that
that's kind of a fad that's going on and
continues to go on right now I don't
think that I mean I'm not a management
guru but it doesn't seem like to me like
the way to run a business really is to
you know cut to the bone and let the
survivors try to soldier on I so you
know I think we we have to look at is
this even good for capitalism in in
corporations in their own terms but some
simple I think rather we call most
proposals I would make I say weak
because they're so obvious and one is
universal health insurance they don't
lose your health insurance and to is
extend unemployment benefits you know
they were up to 15 months in many states
during the recession
they've been most states have cut back
it's just six months now but six months
is the average time it yeah but you know
if you look at the evidence I'm not a
big fan of that idea because with
unemployment insurance you if you look
at the data about what happens is that
people stay unemployed until their
unemployment insurance run out and then
once it runs out that's when they find a
job so when you extend their
unemployment insurance you're just
basically it's almost like a welfare
benefit they get for that period and the
job search doesn't only sixty five
percent of what you have earned and
secondly people want to work people do I
mean the question the work ethic of
people that's a look you know people
care they want they get a sense of
dignity from their work but there are a
lot of people don't I mean this is just
the human nature I know I suppose
they're supposed ten percent or
something all right you know just you
know enjoying their unemployment
benefits and sitting at home and you
know watching TV don't let that go if it
keeps other people and families afloat
mm-hm I think that's more so you would
extend the unemployment insurance for a
longer well yeah I mean in most of
northern Europe you can go months and
months and months right now in Germany
now has instituted plan where you have
to spend some of that time doing
community service work but you know
there's a recognition that in this new
economy where we have outsourcing and I
didn't you know what
sure saying that you know I'm not
challenging corporate decisions here too
much is that you if you're going to have
outsourcing if you're going to insist on
having these really lean corporations
and everything if you're gonna have all
this churning it out you have to have a
safety net for people right now you talk
a to some extent in the book about this
issue of you know why can't we be more
like northern Europe with respect to
things like unemployment insurance and
the universal health care and let me
sort of raise a contrary point about why
we shouldn't which is you know you've
got the economies of northern Europe
which are doing poorly
now especially compared to the United
States they have half the growth rate
that we do we've been growing about four
percent they're at
- they have much you know if you look at
France and Germany for example just to
take two prominent examples there are
unemployment I mean their unemployment
rates are about twice as high as we are
work four point nine there are about ten
percent okay and one employed but but
you know but the other point is even
even your point about you know the
long-term unemployed which is one of the
things you're worried about in the book
and and I worry about that too it's
there's a big difference between the
problem of somebody being unemployed for
six months and somebody for two years
well if you look at the long-term
unemployment rate I looked these up is
that we after after I read the book the
long-term unemployment rates in these
northern European countries are two
three four times higher than they are in
the United States I mean they have
created a system with all of these sort
of social safety nets that you talked
about and the the it's impossible to get
a job in these countries practice things
about France and Germany for example is
that they have not accepted a low wage
economy the way we have and England has
you know our economies have said oh yeah
let's have jobs any job Mac jobs you
know jobs where you earn six seven
dollars an hour they have not they have
strong unions they have stronger
regulations so there is more
unemployment we can't just feel good
about putting everybody to work if
people are working unless they can let
them they can live on something but then
I would also point out Finland I don't
want to live there because of weather
but you know here this is the strongest
welfare state in the world perhaps it's
also got a productivity level as high
and sometimes higher than the United
States
it is a booming economy there's no
contradiction I mean capitalism here I
am am i defending capitalism to you it
does not have to rely on so much human
suffering all the time right there are
capitalist countries that do much better
at taking care of people well I guess I
just my point is I think that there's
more suffering in some of these northern
European countries because you have
people who've been out of jobs for a
long period of time because of the it's
so hard to fight or somebody when they
get employed you know they have such
high minimum wage laws and so on that
they have I think you describe it well
they sort of priced out the lower lungs
of the economic ladder and if you do
that how do people climb
the latter well I think to me the big
difference is if you're a long-term
unemployed person and Finland you're
probably not begging on the street
you're not to begging on the street
there are no beggars I can tell you I
mean I don't know I'm thinking about
Finland yeah been there recently and you
know that we have not we have not put
given people a buffer a cushion in the
face of great the great turmoil turmoil
of our economy how would you change the
this whole industry if it's developed
around the unemployed that you talked so
much about that you went through over
the last ten months how how would you
like to see that changed I mean some of
it doesn't it sounds like some of this
stuff doesn't add any value at all and
they're just people if they're siphoning
off the unemployed but how would you
like to see the whole system work better
well I if I had the resources would set
up network group networking groups and
groups people could go to white and blue
collar people whoever where people could
tell their stories could exchange
information on how to economize whatever
maybe forms some cooperative ways of
dealing with some problems in their
lives childcare or whatever and would
would become lobbying groups for you
know on universal health insurance and
better a better deal for out-of-work
people that's what I would do and is
that happening I mean it's there is the
market moving in that direction there
are some little signs there's a group
called washtech of laid off high-tech
workers and they you know that
represents me it's not a union you know
they're people try to get together in
these ways that are associations but not
unions some some way of coming together
because you know that's an old American
way of dealing with problems too you
come together you share some resources
you share ideas and you you put your
shoulders together one of the things you
talk about at the end too is you you
take a swing at President Bush's
proposal for these personal accounts for
Social Security which is something that
I've been working on for the last few
years and you say that this won't
benefit workers that it'll eviscerate
Social Security and I
you know someone differently that this
is something that actually will allow
Americans to become shareholders and
that it's corporations do better they'll
sort of share in the gains a kind of
rising tide lifts all boats kind of
philosophy what is it that you oppose
about this idea about the personal
accounts for social security that
President Bush has proposed well you
know you just picked up on one line I
think in the book and you're more of an
expert than I am on this but I would say
I don't want to have a risk any risk in
the area of my old age my financing for
my old age I want that to be guaranteed
if I make extra money all right I can
gamble with some of that and see what
happens but I want something that I can
count on and that's what is scary and I
think in a part of what's torpedoing
this social so-called social security
reform is that people are seeing when
you freshen this before but I'll say it
again private pensions diminish and
private pensions become more risky
defined been you know defined
contribution rather than define benefit
so I think you know there's a lot of I'm
not the only one who's really worried
about that security what if worker you
just gave workers choice and you just
said if you want to have what you want
which is a secure you know system where
you're guaranteed a certain benefit you
can stay in Social Security but for
workers who want to be able to tap into
the power of the market and tap into
this power of compound interest through
that but of course you start undermining
the very idea of a shared risk when you
start allowing people to peel off I mean
that's what happens in health insurance
and it's so destructive to health
insurance plans you know the companies
want to cherry-pick the healthy people
who will never need benefits or more for
years anyway and the whole idea of a
shared risk is you have the healthy
people and the chronically ill people
for example or the high-risk people in
the same you know group well the reason
I've never liked that idea is that then
your take then you're basically
essentially saying that personal
responsibility and personal health care
has nothing to do with your medical
class but you know there are a lot of
estimates that about half of medical
costs are attributable to personal
lifetime lifestyle decisions like you
know smoking and overeating and engaging
in kinds of activities that are bad for
your health and why should one person
who does the right things it's like
saying everybody should have to have pay
the same auto insurance premiums even
though I'm a lousy driver and you're a
safe driver well you know already
they're higher premiums for smokers and
things like that but I think there are
very powerful incentives to stay healthy
other you know beyond the smoke a lot of
people in there a lot of exercise
there's a lot of Education because I
know so you know there right now we
don't even know for sure in a couple of
years they might say what you weren't
taking vitamins E every day you know
well too bad for you we don't even know
about so has some I don't think that's
fair you have a a quote at the yet near
the end of the book from Steve steven
kobe who of course is the author of this
one of the most fabulously successful
books of all time the seven Habits of
Highly Effective People and you talked
about his 8th habit is he has a new book
out beyond that and you have a quote in
here from him and I'd just like you to
comment on it you say the that he writes
there's this call in need of a new era
for for greatness it's for fulfillment
passionate execution and significant
contribution in the work force that that
seems to be a exactly right that that's
actually precisely what employers are
looking for greatness and people were
passionately committed to their job and
so on
are there enough American workers who
feel that passion I don't like this idea
of the passionate employee that's what I
was talking about here with Ashley why
don't you like it because people are
churning in and out of job so quickly I
think it's a lot to ask somebody to be
well I mean I believe in being
passionate about one's work I am
passionate about my I'm sure you are
about yours but if it changes every year
or two if it you know if you're getting
even
Casta how do you regenerate all that
passion for the next one would maybe in
a completely different area or subject
so I'm commenting in the context of this
churning of white-collar workers that
you know it used to be when it was
Stephen Covey wrote about the seven
Habits here about effectiveness right
you get the job done right now suddenly
that's not a fashion if you have to be
passionate you have to experience some
kind of like romantic love for your job
which i think is fine unless that job is
changing you know without your
permission and voluntarily again and
again